GREG, IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY
AND THIS IS "THE FIVE."
THE DEMOCRATS PREPARING TO GO
PUBLIC WITH THEIR ONE-SIDED
IMPEACHMENT PROBE THAT IS
SHAPING UP TO BE ANYTHING BUT
FAIR.
RUSH LIMBAUGH PREDICTS IT IS
GOING TO TURN INTO A
JUDGE KAVANAUGH STYLE DEBACLE.
>> IT WAS A NEVER ENDING PARADE
FOR A WEEK AND A HALF AS EVERY
PERSON THEY BROUGHT FORTH TO TRY
TO DESTROY KAVANAUGH.
FAILED.
THERE WAS ANOTHER ONE WAITING IN
THE WINGS.
AND I WOULD GUARANTEE YOU IT IS
THE SAME STRATEGICALLY THEY ARE
GOING TO EMPLOY HERE THIS WEEK.
THEY ARE GOING SCREW THIS UP
LIKE THEY SCREWED UP THE
KAVANAUGH THING.
THEY WANT IT TOO MUCH.
AND BECAUSE THEY WANT IT TOO
MUCH, THEY ARE MAKING TACTICAL
AND STRATEGIC MISTAKES.
>> Jesse: IF YOU NEED MORE
PROOF THAT THE MEDIA IS
COMPLICIT IN PUSHING THE
DEMOCRATS' TALKING POINTS, CHECK
THIS OUT, MEDIA RESEARCH CENTER
FINDS THAT SINCE IMPEACHMENT
STARTED, NETWORK TV COVERAGE HAS
BEEN 96% NEGATIVE FOR TRUMP.
THIS IS ALL HAPPENING WHILE THE
PRESIDENT LAUNCHES BLISTERING
ATTACKS, CALLING IMPEACHMENT
PROCESS A "NO DUE PROCESS CAN."
HE SAYS THAT JOE BIDEN AND HIS
SON SHOULD TESTIFY BUT SLEEPY
JOE SAYS IT IS NOT NECESSARY.
A SPEAKER THERE IS ZERO
RATIONALE FOR THAT.
NOBODY HAS SUGGESTED ANYTHING
THAT WAS DONE THAT WAS
INAPPROPRIATE.
THIS IS ALL A DIVERSION.
THIS IS CLASSIC TRUMP.
CLASSIC TRUMP.
FOCUS ON THE PROBLEM.
>> Jesse: LET'S GO BACK TO THE
RUSH LIMBAUGH COMMENT, AND AFTER
THAT, HE FOLLOWED THAT WITH THIS
POINT, THAT THEY ARE ALWAYS
PREDICTING TRUMP'S TOAST.
IN THE PRIMARY HE WAS TOAST, AND
THE GENERAL HE WAS TOAST,
MUELLER HE'S TOAST AND NOW THIS
IMPEACHMENT THING.
IT NEVER WORKS OUT.
>> Jesse: AND THEN THEY
PREDICTED THAT HE DIDN'T REALLY
WANT TO WIN ANYWAY AND HE DIDN'T
WANT TO RUN AND THEN HE WAS
GOING TO DROP OUT AND ALL THESE
THINGS.
I THINK THAT THE MEDIA IS
EXPECTING A VERY STRONG
PERFORMANCE OUT OF THE DEMOCRATS
TOMORROW BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE SET THE BAR REALLY HIGH
WHICH MAKES ME THINK, THEY MIGHT
HAVE SOMETHING UP THEIR SLEEVES.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IT IS.
>> Jesse: A CRYING WITNESS?
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW, THE
CRYING WITNESS, I DON'T KNOW.
THAT PROBABLY COMES LATER.
I DON'T THINK YOU START WITH
YOUR WITNESS, BUT I WONDER IF
THEY MIGHT HAVE SOMETHING UP
THEIR SLEEVE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT COULD BE,
BUT IF THEY COULD JUST COME OUT
AND REHASH WHAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT FOR THE LAST SIX
WEEKS, IT SEEMS TO ME THAT WOULD
BE A PRETTY SHORT-LIVED HEARING.
>> Jesse: I DON'T THINK HAVING
SCHIFF RUN THIS THING IS GOOD
OPTICS.
IT'S NOT EASY ON THE EYES, HE IS
ANNOYING WHEN HE OPENS HIS
MOUTH, AND HE IS JUST NOT
TRUSTWORTHY.
>> Greg: HE HAS A PROBLEM AND
THAT WE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT HE IS
GOING TO DO AND THEN HE DOES IT
HORRIBLY.
I DON'T THINK IT IS GOING TO BE
LIKE KAVANAUGH AT ALL.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE THAT
INTERESTING BECAUSE IT IS ABOUT
A PHONE CALL, IT'S ABOUT A
PRESIDENT DOING HIS JOB AND IT'S
ABOUT THE OPINIONS ABOUT WHETHER
IT IS APPROPRIATE OR
INAPPROPRIATE.
IT'S ABOUT OPINIONS.
HERE'S MY PRODUCTION, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO DO THEIR
BEST TO DRAW OUT THE EMOTION BY
USING QUESTIONS LIKE, "DID YOU
FEEL THREATENED?
HOW DID IT MAKE YOU FEEL?"
IT'S BASICALLY GOING TO BE GROUP
THERAPY IN WHICH THE SHRINK IS
GOING TO BE ASKING THE CHILDREN,
HOW MEAN WHAT IS YOUR DADDY?
TRUMP BEING THE DADDY.
YOUR POINT YESTERDAY ABOUT HOW
THE MEDIA HAD TO CHANGE THE
LANGUAGE, ANDERSON COOPER LAST
NIGHT SAID TRUMP WAS
ORCHESTRATING A SHAKEDOWN.
HOW DO YOU ORCHESTRATE A
SHAKEDOWN IN PUBLIC WHEN YOU
WANT UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS TO
PUBLICIZE IT AND THE PERSON
BEING SHUT DOWN IS COMPLETELY
UNAWARE THEY ARE BEING SHIPPED
DOWN.
I THINK THEY REALIZED THAT QUID
PRO QUO IS A NO-GO.
THEY ARE DESPERATE FOR A NEW
LANGUAGE, AND THIS IS GOING TO
BE FAILED.
THE BEST THE MEDIA CAN DO RIGHT
NOW, BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
THE DEMOCRATS, IT'S ABOUT THE
MEDIA, THEY ARE HOPING WE ALL
SUIT UP AND TAKE THIS GAME
SERIOUSLY BECAUSE THEY ARE
TAKING IT SERIOUSLY.
THEY WANT US TO.
BUT YOU NEED TO LOOK AT
IMPEACHMENT LIKE A JUNKIE
DANCING IN HIS UNDERWEAR ON A
STREET CORNER.
IT'S A VERY EXPERIENCED, IT'S
NOT YOURS.
IT'S WHAT THEY ARE LIVING, BUT
IT'S NOT YOURS.
THE MEDIA'S STRATEGY IS
PREVENTATIVE INTERVENTION.
CNN IS TRYING TO GET THE PUBLIC
TO BE SO INTERESTED IN THIS,
"PLEASE, THIS IS SO IMPORTANT."
BUT IT'S NOT HAPPENING.
EVERYONE KNOWS IT'S GOING TO BE
PEOPLE WHINING ABOUT A PHONE
CALL.
THIS THING IS GOING TO PETER OUT
IN AN HOUR.
>> Jesse: MAY BE SCHIFF'S
SECRET IS GOING TO BE A DANCING
JUNKIE IN HIS UNDERWEAR.
I WOULD WATCH THAT ONE.
>> Greg: COME ON OVER TO MY
PLACE.
>> Jesse: WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT GREG'S POINT, THAT THE
SO-CALLED SCANDAL DOESN'T HAVE
THE EMOTIONAL FIREPOWER THAT
OTHER SCANDALS HAVE HAD?
>> Juan: I KNOW YOU ARE A
YOUNG MAN BY JOHN DEAN SAT THERE
IN HIS MONOTONE AND IN A WEEK
THE NUMBERS TUMBLED FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
AMERICA JUST SAID, WAIT A
MINUTE?
WHAT IS HE SAYING?
THAT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
SO THAT'S NOT IT.
TO ME, WHAT WE GOT HERE IS AN
EFFORT, AND GREG REFLECTS THIS,
THE STATE OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, FORGET ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS A BORE.
IT'S NOT INTERESTING.
>> Greg: IT'S NOT REAL.
>> Juan: IS NOT EVEN CLINTON.
BUT THIS IS MUCH MORE IMPORTANT,
IN MY OPINION.
THIS REQUIRES PEOPLE, THE
REPUBLICANS, TO SAY YES, THERE
IS A MOUNTAIN OF EVIDENCE, BUT
DON'T LOOK!
LOOK AT THE RAINBOWS, LOOK AT
THE RAINBOWS IN EVERY DIRECTION!
IT IS TRIBAL BLINDNESS.
IF THIS WAS OBAMA, IF THIS WAS
HILLARY CLINTON, THEY WOULD SAY
HANG HIM FROM THE HIGHEST TREE,
THIS IS TREASON.
>> Greg: WE WOULD HANG OBAMA?
>> Juan: THE G.O.P. DEFENSE
MEMO THAT CAME OUT YESTERDAY,
HERE IS WHAT OUR STRATEGY IS FOR
THIS, ATTACKED THE WITNESSES,
ATTACK THE CREDIBILITY OF
WILLIAM TAYLOR.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU DO THAT, HE
IS A TRUMP GUY.
GEORGE CHAM, THE OTHER GUY THAT
IS GOING TO TESTIFY TOMORROW.
THESE ARE NEVER-TRUMPERS.
THEY WERE HIRED BY MIKE POMPEO,
BY TRUMP.
SHIFT THE DISCUSSION AWAY FROM
TRUMP.
LET'S TALK ABOUT JOE BIDEN,
LET'S TALK ABOUT HUNTER.
ARE THEY UNDER THREAT --
>> Greg: BUT THEY ARE PART OF
THIS AND YOU CAN'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT!
>> Juan: THIS IS ABOUT
IMPEACHING PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Jesse: YOU CAN STILL, AS HE
SAYS, HAVE A MOUNTAIN OF
EVIDENCE, BUT IT DOESN'T ADD UP
TO A HIGH CRIME AND MISDEMEANOR.
IT IS JUST A MOUNTAIN OF
SOMETHING ELSE.
>> Juan: OH GOSH.
>> Katie: GO BACK TO WHAT THE
PRESIDENT'S PHONE CALL SAID, AND
THAT IS WHAT HE'S BEEN ARGUING
THEY CAN DO.
THE QUESTION ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN
IS AN INTERESTING ONE BECAUSE
BEFORE THIS COMPLAINT WAS FILED,
THE NEW YORKER BRAND THE PIECE
ON JULY 1ST ASKING THE QUESTION
OF WHETHER HUNTER BIDEN WAS
GOING TO DERAIL HIS FATHER'S
CAMPAIGN BECAUSE OF ALL THE
CORRUPTION ALLEGATION IN
UKRAINE.
BEFORE IT WAS POPULAR TO SAY
TRUMP WAS THE ONLY ONE ATTACKING
HUNTER BIDEN BUT THE MEDIA WAS
ACTUALLY DOING EXPOSES ON THIS.
AS WE POINTED OUT BEFORE, THE
OBAMA CAMPAIGN ACTUALLY LOOKED
INTO SOME OF THIS AND JOE BIDEN
GOT VERY UPSET THAT THEY WERE
KIND OF CIRCLING AROUND TO SEE
MAYBE WHAT CAUSED A PROBLEM FOR
THE OBAMA CAMPAIGN.
BUT WHY WOULDN'T SOMEONE LIKE
HUNTER BIDEN WANT TO COME IN
FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE,
VOLUNTARILY, TO CLEAR HIS NAME?
HE'S BEEN ACCUSED OF A LOT,
THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF RUMORS
ABOUT HIS DEALINGS.
IT SEEMS LIKE HE WOULD TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO AND CLEAR UP
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN OF ANY
WRONGDOING TO SAY THAT THIS CALL
REALLY WAS ABOUT GOING FORWARD
IN USING YOUR POLITICAL POWER AS
A PRESIDENT TO GO AFTER
POLITICAL OPPONENT.
BUT HE IS NOT VOLUNTARILY DOING
IT.
ADAM SCHIFF IS BLOCKING HIM AND
REFUSING TO BRING ANY REPUBLICAN
REQUESTER WITNESSES, WHICH SHOWS
THEY ARE NOT INTERESTED IN A
FAIR PROCESS, ESPECIALLY WHEN
THE VOTE WAS SO BY PARTY LINES
IN TERMS OF MOVING IT FORWARD.
>> Jesse: EAT THEM ADAM SCHIFF
IS NOT
STUPID ENOUGH TO BRING HUNTER TO
TESTIFY.